und diese fragen wollen wir besprechen
wir jetzt mit frau professor claudia
kemfert vom deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung guten morgen guten
morgen wir gerade gehört
wirtschaftsminister und vizekanzler
robert habeck befürchtet möglicherweise
ab dem 11 juli eine komplette blockade
der gaslieferungen was würde das für
unsere gas kapazitäten im winter
bedeuten wie viel wird dann noch da sein
ja alles kommt jetzt darauf an inwieweit
es gelingt die speicher zu füllen wir
bekommen ja noch gas auch aus norwegen
oder aus anderen regionen
der wirtschaftsminister hat ja
vorgesorgt indem ja auch also sogenannte
flüssiggasterminals also schwimmende
flüssiggas terminals in norddeutschland
installiert werden darüber würden wir
auch gas bekommen also insofern auch
genügend jetzt noch für diesen winter
also wenn es gelingt dass die speicher
gefüllt werden auf 80 prozent bis zum
ersten oktober und 90% bis zum ersten
november dann kommen wir sehr gut durch
den winter dann erwarte ich gar keine
geheimen sicher ist für wahrscheinlich
also da wird es jetzt alles darauf
ankommen ob das gelingt also ob wir da
wirklich genügend gas in den nächsten
monaten bekommen um das zu schaffen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir alles
dafür tun und gas einzusparen dafür
sorgt man jetzt ja auch dass man weniger
das nutzte um es zu verstromen sondern
dass man jetzt wirklich alles dafür tut
deswegen will man ja mehr kohle auch
kurzfristig nutzen aber alles dafür tut
dass gas eingespart wird über die
sparsamkeit möchte gleich noch mal
ausführlicher sprechen möchte aber
zusammen mit ihnen noch auf das
zdf-politbarometer zu diesem thema
schauen bei der versorgung mit erdgas im
kommenden winter sehen in unserem
politbarometer nämlich 58 prozent der
befragten probleme für privathaushalte
und sogar 75 prozent der befragten sehen
dann die industrie in schwierigkeiten
was würden sie dann erklären für wen
werden die probleme möglicherweise
größer werden für die privaten haushalte
oder für die industrie also alles kommt
es wirklich darauf an dass wir schnell
sparen wir sehen heute dass tatsächlich
die industrie schon wahnsinnig weniger
in der gas verbraucht also insbesondere
gas ist sehr wichtig über zehn prozent
schon so ist der verbrauch schon gesenkt
worden das hilft schon dass es das eine
und das zweite ist ob es wirklich
gelingt dann die speicher zu füllen
hätten wir im winter tatsächlich gar
keine gasknappheit wenn es so kommen
sollte das tatsächlich knappheiten
auftreten dann wäre das ende nächsten
winters und dann würde in der tat in
erster linie die industrie betroffen
seien weniger die privathaushalte aber
auch da gilt jetzt schon vorbereiten
alles was geht um tatsächlich gas
einzusparen es werden über thermostate
geredet oder auch andere möglichkeiten
wenn man jetzt die chance hat die
gasheizung zu wechseln wäre das
natürlich sinnvoll erschafft man
wahrscheinlich nicht aber hier kommt
jetzt alles darauf an dass wir möglichst
viel gas einsparen gehen wir aber mal an
ist gelingt nicht jetzt hat gesagt vor
allem die industrie sei wäre dann
betroffen möglicherweise aber auch die
privathaushalte können sie uns erklären
welche art von einschränkungen das
bedeuten könnte also im moment gibt es
sogenannte auktionen dass die industrie
sich bewirbt und sagt man könnte denn
gas runter gefahren werden dann könnte
der gasverbrauch reduziert werden zum
beispiel über kurzarbeit oder dass man
bestimmte produktionsprozesse erstmal
runter fährt und dafür bekommen sie
entschädigung dh die wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen wären nicht so groß das
wird man jetzt vorbereiten oder das
passiert jetzt gerade aktuell das heißt
hier versucht man wirklich auch
marktwirtschaftliches halte ich auch für
sinnvoll vorzugehen um da auch
entschädigungen zu haben um diese
prozesse wirklich auch steuern zu können
dass man am ende wirklich etwas
abschalten muss das versucht man eher zu
vermeiden und das halte ich auch für
sinnvoll dass man das dass man jetzt
alles macht um das zu verhindern denn
gerade schon auch angesprochen dass der
gasverbrauch fast erstaunlicherweise
schon deutlich gesunken ist zum einen
frage ich mich woran genau das liebt und
welches weitere einspar potenzial ist
möglicherweise auch bei uns privaten
haushalten gibt also wie viele es
wirklich bringen ja wir sind in einer
existierenden funktionierenden
marktwirtschaft das heißt der preis für
gas explodiert im moment und das ist
sehr genau der grund warum der
gasverbrauch rapide nach unten geht die
unternehmen orientieren sich um kaufen
weniger machen andere
produktionsverfahren das passiert schon
aktuell das heißt wenn wir 20 prozent
einsparen ist schon wirklich ein
großteil der miete tatsächlich geschafft
und wir müssen überhaupt gar nicht über
gasknappheit nachdenken weiterhin kommt
es darauf an wie das jetzt weitergeht
weil die verbraucher werden den sehr
stark steigenden gaspreis es im winter
mehr in diesem und im nächsten jahr
gibt's brutale preissteigerungen darauf
muss man sich jetzt schon vorbereiten
das ist bis zu 400 prozent
preissteigerungen möglich und darauf
muss man sich jetzt eben auch als
verbraucher vorbereiten dass man da
entsprechend geld beiseite legt claudia
kempfert war das energie expertin vom
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung ganz herzlichen
dank für ihre erklärung haben sie ihnen